and camera and move it
our guiding principal for music was to
be rooted in the time but to really push
the edges of what we normally expect
I was blown away by the script and once
we started talking about what the score
could be what if we use the
instrumentation of a 1920s jazz band but
hinting at rock and roll and modern
dance music I got very excited about it
we wanted music that was more aggressive
failure
more in your face we've gotta innovate
we've gotta Inspire Justin has been
working on this music even before we
began shooting so you feel that in the
work there's no doubt in my mind this is
a score for the ages
Justin's music gives me chills it's
really really beautiful
so we want to build Plateau build
Plateau Bill Plateau to get to play some
of the songs brilliantly composed by
Justin who got those cameras pointed in
the wrong direction
I mean it was really cool
tracks like the one that you heard that
this opening party
is full of Wilds all those screaming
sacks wailing trumpet and creating the
sound of that perk
that's banging shoe horns wood hitting
the floor of my home literally it's
unhinged in like a beautiful way
putting it all together like the amount
of sessions the amount of players in
this movie
it's been a really complicated but
gratifying score to put together
foreign